[Applaudissements]
il ya cinq ans j'ai pris une bonne
grosse claque
mais attention pas une claque au sens
physique non plutôt une claque
intellectuelle mais tellement forte que
j'en suis quand même tombé de haut j'ai
cru à ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui
ni norme fake news et cette claque m'a
fait découvrir la zététique mais avant
de vous dire ce qu'est la zététique je
vais commencer par le début de
l'histoire de mes petites croyances
alors tout a commencé dans un
environnement familial très empreint
d'ésotérisme
quand j'étais petit j'ai croisé la route
de radiesthésistes de magnétiseur ces
gens qui captait des énergies à l'aide
d'un pendule ou tout simplement avec
leurs mains et je me souviens aussi de
se soucier qui était venu chez moi dans
mon jardin pour trouver de l'eau bizarre
non
sans trop me poser de questions je
croyais qu'il existait vraiment des gens
sur terre et pas loin de chez moi
d'ailleurs doté de pouvoirs particuliers
et j'ai trimballé très bel essai petit
croyances durant toute mon enfance et
même après jusqu'à ma vie d'étudiant ou
là j'ai eu d'autres types de petites
croyances les théories du complot alors
à la base moins à cette époque je
voulais comprendre le monde avec un oeil
critique système savez le système
politique que danic le système
médiatique
du coup je lisais un peu mais je
regardais surtout beaucoup de
documentaires et de vidéos sur youtube
et sur internet
et très rapidement je me suis mis à
suivre des personnalités d'internet
qu'on qualifiera de peu recommandables
du genre à diffuser entre autres des
vidéos complotistes j'étais entré dans
la complice faire vous connaissez sans
doute la version officielle des tristes
attentats du 11 septembre 2001 et bien
moi je pourrais vous raconter les mille
versions complotistes c'est parti non
quand même je vais pas vous infliger ça
ce soir
par contre un jour je suis tombé sur le
documentaire et là je vais vous dire
c'était pas complotistes mais quand même
c'est un documentaire du genre petite
voix secrète montage vidéo bien ficelé
interventions d'experts ingénieurs
évidemment musique qui fait peur et une
révélation et la révélation mesdames et
messieurs c'était que les pyramides
situé sur le plateau de gizeh en egypte
comme la pyramide de khéops n'avait
peut-être pas été construites par les
égyptiens alors partie par quoi
c'était pas dit mais moi je suis partie
super loin
non vraiment j'ai été tellement à fond
j'ai tout gober mais le pire c'est que
le documentaire bajeux les diffuser je
les diffuser partout autour de moi ma
famille à mes amis et encore aujourd'hui
on en rigole parce que bon il ya un
moment où j'ai compris j'ai compris que
c'était complètement bidon biaisé et
truffé d'erreurs et moi bah j'avais cru
à ça et c'est comme ça que je me suis
pris cette grosse claque
je vois avec la suite fut aussi
difficile qu un lendemain de cuite mais
c'est quand même grâce à ça que j'ai mis
le pied dans un autre monde
le monde de l'esprit critique
vous savez on n'aurait pas besoin de
lois contre les faits que muse si on
disposait tous de ce merveilleux filtre
quel esprit critique et moi c'est de ça
dont j'avais besoin à cette époque je
pense qu'on en a tous besoin est de plus
en plus dans cette société de l'hyper
l'information et du tout numérique
l'esprit critique c'est comme une lampe
torche qui permet d'avancer dans cette
jungle d'information aidant ma lampe et
plus de piles
et pourtant pourtant j'étais en master 2
à bac + 5
sans dire est que jeter une lumière on
aurait quand même pu penser que j'étais
armé face à ce genre d'intox
et bien non en fait des travaux en
psychologie montrent que c'est pas parce
que vous faites plus d'études que vous
aurez un meilleur esprit critique donc
en fin de compte on est tous concernés
bon final moi j'en suis pas si mécontent
de toute cette histoire des pyramides
car c'est comme ça que j'ai découvert la
zététique alors la zététique c'est quoi
et bien c'est cette discipline qui
permet de stimuler et de développer
l'esprit critique et éthiques
ça vient du grec éteignent qui veut dire
chercher il y à bien longtemps la
zététique se définissait comme la
méthode dont on se sert pour pénétrer la
raison des choses bon ça c'est déjà bien
longtemps
heureusement dans les années 80 c'est le
professeur henri broc biophysicien à
l'université de nice est reconnue en
france comme le père de la zététique qui
a remis au goût du jour ce mot aussi
ancien que blizzard et le définit lui
même la zététique comme l'art du tout
utilisé le doute comme un moyen comme un
moyen et non comme une fin en soi l'idée
n'est pas de douter de tout et tout le
temps n'ont aucun intérêt douter certes
mais pas n'importe comment et pas de
n'importe quoi car aujourd'hui la
zététique s'entend comme la méthode
d'investigation scientifique des
phénomènes réputé paranormaux la méthode
phénomènes réputé paranormaux
investiguer voilà ce que fait heins et
éthicien en quelque sorte il mène
l'enquêté pour tirer au clair des sujets
flou et c'est en menant l'enquêté qu'il
développe son esprit critique
comment mène-t-il enquête il ya mesdames
et messieurs tout simplement avec
méthode
avec la méthode scientifique ce puissant
outil qui nous a quand même permis
d'éradiquer certaines maladies comme la
variole ou de réussir les défis les plus
fous comme poser des robots sur mars à
76 millions de kilomètres d'ici plutôt
pas mal non
et bien malheureusement on a tendance à
l'oublier mais la méthode scientifique
est la meilleure méthode que l'homme a
trouvé jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour acquérir
et développer des connaissances solides
sur notre monde et la zététique se sert
de cette méthode de cet outil puissant
pour investiguer les sujets un peu floue
que sont les phénomènes paranormaux
toute ma vie j'ai tourné autour de ces
sujets bizarroïdes
c'est pas étonnant tu as vraiment à un
hasard si la zététique a eu un fort écho
en moi un moment de ma vie avec cette
discipline je suis revenue creuser un
peu tout ça un peu comme un enfant à qui
on fait un tour de magie et qui souhaite
ensuite savoir absolument quel est le
truc mais attention en et éthiques
l'idée n'est pas de ranger tous les gens
qui prétendent avoir un don un pouvoir
dans la case charlatans c'est sûr qu'il
en existe mais la plupart des gens que
moi j'ai connu personnellement où j'ai
étudié via la zététique pense souvent de
bonne foi possédez un réel pouvoir hors
du commun
il ne pense simplement pas à réaliser de
petites expériences assez simple pour
s'auto évaluer et le mieux pour
comprendre c'est de prendre un exemple
un jour un médium est venu voir le
professeur henri broc en affirmant que
dans une petite pièce la porte presque
fermé il était capable en se concentrant
rien qu'à la force de son esprit de
faire bouger la porte de bonne foi
vraiment
il pensait qu'il avait là un véritable
don un don de télékinésie
un don qui défie évidemment toutes les
lois de la physique établis jusque là le
pouvoir de l'esprit directement sur la
matière bref un cap parfait pour faire
de la zététique et c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans ce genre d'allégations
extraordinaire
l'art du doute la zététique conseil en
premier lieu de suspendre son jugement
plutôt que de vouloir à tout prix donner
son opinion j'y crois j'y crois pas mais
si j'ai entendu que c'était un doute et
d'abord pour prendre le temps de
réfléchir et se poser les questions se
posaient les questions comme quel test
on pourrait bien faire pour évaluer ce
qui se passe vraiment c'est ce qu'a fait
henry broc
vous savez quoi la réalisation de
l'expérience au sein de son laboratoire
de zététique conclut et bien que dans
une petite pièce dans cette petite pièce
ce médium lorsqu'il se concentrait
arrivé effectivement à faire bouger la
porte
fantastique oui oui mais y avait un
maire ce que l'homme ce médium de bonne
foi avait oublié de mentionner c'était
qu'en plus de se concentrer
il se contractait en respirant ce grand
gaillard d'un mètre 90 est contracté ses
pectoraux et ses abdominaux et ce qui se
passait c'est qu'il crée de cette
manière une variation du volume
accessible à l'air assez faible mais
suffisante pour créer une variation de
la pression de l'air dans cette petite
pièce et c'est la pression de l'air qui
faisait bouger la porte
eurêka
avec ce cas de zététique pratique vous
voyez simplement comment il est facile
sans prise de recul de tomber dans le
piège de l'explication extraordinaire du
don surnaturel
derrière chaque phénomène étrange
derrière chaque faculté extra
sensorielle il ya des choses
passionnantes à apprendre sur l'objet de
l'étude
parfois sur nous mêmes il ya aussi des
supers principe de zététique à découvrir
et dans le cas de ce médium c'était
celui qui dit que l'alternative est
féconde
il ya beaucoup de principe en est
éthique pour moi suit est essentielle
l'alternative est féconde dans ce genre
de cas à vendre avant de découvrir la
zététique moi je me fiais aux
témoignages des gens je me fie à leur
bonne foi
aujourd'hui je demande des preuves
évidemment aussi bonne que possible mais
j'essaye aussi de rechercher l'hypothèse
alternative dans le cas de ce médium on
se rend bien compte que l'explication
surnaturel le don de télékinésie marche
moins bien que l'explication naturel
physique qui a était l'hypothèse
alternative à trouver je dois avouer que
dans ce cas là ce n'était pas évident de
trouver l'hypothèse alternative
l'hypothèse concurrentes
on dit aussi mais la plupart du temps
franchement en cherchant un peu c'est
d'une extrême simplicité
tenez plus tôt je vous ai parlé de mes
complot sur le 11 septembre
et bien pour tout vous dire même après
avoir découvert la zététique j ai
longtemps cru s'est un peu fait exprès
en fait je prends tellement de plaisir à
me remettre en question
dans une sorte d'auto dérision de toutes
mes petites croyances infondées depuis
le début de ma vie que je me suis gardé
le meilleur pour la fin le 11 septembre
mon dernier bastion et pour détruire ce
dernier bastion j'ai simplement fait une
recherche d'alternatives en tapant en
septembre complots et des bonnes cage le
mot anglais des bonnes cage signifie
déconstruction des mystifications donc
on septembre complot des constructions
résultat en faisant ça je suis tombé sur
des explications alternatives aux thèses
complotistes et qui me paraissait bien
plus vraisemblable que ce que je croyais
avant
c'est un peu en faisant ça et avec un
malin plaisir que j'ai lâché la faire
avec mais complot du 11 septembre
ceux des pyramides ils tous les autres
j'ai pas le temps de vous parler ce soir
mais y en avait un paquet l'alternative
est féconde donc la question qui reste
en suspens c'est pourquoi ne va-t-on pas
recherché l'hypothèse alternative
l'argument contradictoires l'idée
opposés alors que c'est souvent si
simple la réponse le biais de
confirmation cette tendance qu'on a tous
en commun à aller chercher des
informations qui nous conforte dans nos
idées dans nos croyances
après toutes ces années de petites
croyances infondées j'ai compris que mon
plus grand ennemi
et bien en fait c'était moi même moi
même ou plus exactement les mécanismes
ma pensée tous ces biais psychologiques
qui viennent altérer ma ma raison avant
je voulais comprendre le monde et avec
la zététique en apprenant ne pas se
faire avoir par des allégations
extraordinaire eh bien j'ai appris à pas
me faire avoir tout court bon à moins
faire avoir
à moins de faire avoir sur autant de
sujets impactant que sont la politique
les médias la publicité la santé etc etc
beaucoup de sujets nécessitent d'avoir
un esprit critique bien aiguisé
et c'est là pour moi la portée politique
de cette discipline la zététique qui
contribue à la diffusion d'une auto
défense intellectuelles nécessaires aux
citoyens que nous sommes tous le chemin
de la pensée critique demande curiosité
d'esprit c'est important la curiosité
n'est pas un vilain défaut
mais il demande aussi humilité devant la
fragilité de notre raison du travail
il travail méthodique c'est un
merveilleux chemin que je vous propose
vous aussi d'emprunter mais attention je
vous demande pas de me suivre
me croire sur parole car comme on le dit
souvent aux et éthiques
ne prenez pas pour argent comptant tout
ce qu'on vous dit même si l'individu
vous paraître bonne foi de confiance
même s'il s'exprime bien même s'il a de
bons arguments
en apparence et même s'ils portent une
belle chemise bleue merci
[Applaudissements]
mais en fait qu'est-ce qui vous prouve
que le mot même de zététique existe
vraiment merci d'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]